So my last video on MLM's multi level marketing
did ruffles and feathers,
and honestly,
it was a joke.
But now, um, ha ha ha.
I'm gonna show you
financial disclosure list of how much, um,
the average person makes with MLM companies.
Okay, so let's start with Monet. Okay,
so these are the different tears that you have here.
Okay, this tear right here,
that's 92% of people who sell Monet.
Let's take a gamble on how much they make.
Do you have your guess?
Okay, on average,
they make $133 a year.
Okay, now let's look at young living.
Okay, this is 64.
64% of their partners.
What do we think they made
the highest?
Almost $600.
The average is $22, guys.
The average is $22.
And now let's look at Amir. Amir,
I don't know how you say this one,
to be honest,
but it's the people that sell, like,
the happy juice stuff
who are promising you that you're gonna have great gut
health food,
drink this juice.
Um, Brand Partners.
Let's see what percentage, uh,
it is 86% of the people who sell it.
And now let's see if you got your guess.
$25 a month.
See average compensation that.
Only picking these companies
because they're probably the most popular ones
that I see a lot.
But just so you know,
MLMs who promised you
that you're gonna make thousands of dollars.
Unless you were in like
the top percentage,
you're not person who's promising You
that you can make a lovable income at home
on your phone?
No. Based on these stats, no.
Can you? Sure. Maybe.
I don't know
cause I've never done it.
But I would like to see actual income stats
from people who say this.
Some line is that
MLMs are not a get rich quick situation.
You're not gonna make
the average person.
I'll just say
the average person is not gonna make, um,
thousands of dollars doing it.
So just have some discernment.
Probably going to be the last time
I'm talking about Emma Lunch
because for some reason
they're so controversial.
But just thought I'd put this out there
if you want the general info.